y llevamos jugando con nuestros
determinantes para ver si podemos
encontrar otras propiedades muy útiles
que aunque no las vayamos a usar ahorita
seguro las vamos a necesitar cuando
estemos en algún otro tema de álgebra
lineal entonces digamos que tengo aquí
una matriz llamémosle x
y esta matriz va a ser una matriz de 2 x
2 donde su primera fila va a ser la
misma fila de siempre la fila a b pero
la segunda fila le vamos a llamar en
lugar de llamarle 6 como siempre le
vamos a llamar x1 y x2 más adelante tú
solo te vas a dar cuenta de por qué le
estoy llamando así y también tenemos
otra matriz a la cual le vamos a llamar
ye que va a ser exactamente idéntica de
la matriz x en la primera fila de aquí
va a tener ave pero en la segunda fila
tiene cualquier otra cosa
digamos g1 y g2
y además tenemos una tercera matriz la
matriz zeta que es igualita a estas dos
matrices en su primera fila o sea tiene
aquí a b pero en su segunda fila esta
fila va a resultar ser la suma de estas
dos filas aunque aquí va a tener x uno
más de uno y en esta entrada va a tener
x2 más de dos que está zeta no es para
nada la suma de las matrices xy aunque
por ejemplo aquí este término esta no es
la suma de a massa porque aquí
tendríamos dos a éste simplemente a
estamos dejando toda esta fila tal cual
igualita a estas dos entonces z
definitivamente no es igual a x + d
pero bueno algo que vas a notar lo vimos
en el vídeo pasado y lo vamos a ver en
este vídeo es que el determinante no es
lineal con respecto a las operaciones
entre matrices o sea el determinante de
k por aa como vimos no era igualito acá
por el determinante de a y lo mismo pasa
para la suma el determinante de x + d no
es igual al determinante de x más el
determinante de y pero resulta que el
determinante aunque no es lineal para
las operaciones entre matrices si es
lineal en cierta medida o sea si es
lineal para las operaciones que le
hagamos a una sola fila de la matriz
pero bueno empecemos por ver cómo se
relacionan estos tres determinantes
tenemos aquí el determinante de x
determinante de x que es igual a esto sí
ya lo hemos hecho un millón de veces es
a x x2 x x 2 - b por x17 bien el
determinante de y determinante de g es
igual a apoyados por dos menos b porque
uno menos
deport de uno y finalmente el
determinante de zeta es igual a
por x2 más de 2 x 2 + 2
- v x x 11 de x x 1 más de uno
entonces vamos a desarrollar esta
multiplicación y nos queda a preki dos
más apoyados por x 2 más a x 2 - b por x
1 - b porque 17 bien y ahora pues vamos
a reacomodar estos términos de manera
conveniente aquí vamos a ponerle a x x 2
x x 2 - b x x 1 - b x x 1 aunque tenemos
a por x 2 que es este término menos b
por x 1 - p por x 1 y después vamos a
sumarle a x 2 que es este término menos
b porque 1 y ahora si ya podemos ver la
relación entre estos dos determinantes y
este determinante resulta que
a x2 b x 1 es igualito a esto o sea esto
de aquí este con éste que es este es
igualito al determinante de x y estoy
acá que es hayedos menos 21 es igualito
al determinante de y ok entonces estos
dos son igualitos al determinante de iu
y se están sumando entonces el
determinante de zeta es igual al
determinante de x más el determinante
del ojo z para nada es la suma de x + ok
y esta propiedad sólo se da porque estas
tres matrices son iguales en toda la
matriz excepto en una fila en esta fila
que bueno se ve como la mitad de la
matriz pero eso es sólo porque estamos
viendo matrices de 2 x 2 y bueno
entonces iceta x y ya son iguales en
toda la matriz excepto en una fila
y resulta ser que justo en esa fila en
la que son distintas la fila de zeta es
igual a la suma de las filas de xy
entonces y sólo en ese caso podemos
concluir que el determinante de zeta es
igual al determinante de x más el
determinante de y ok es muy importante
eso de que son y velitas en el resto de
la matriz excepto en esa fila a ver
vamos a empezar por ver otro ejemplo
vamos a hacer lo mismo pero para
matrices de 3 por 3 y después vamos al
caso más general con matrices de n por n
que en realidad hacer esta demostración
para matrices de n por n es lo más
sencillo pero como es muy abstracto
vamos a empezar por el de 3 x 3
entonces empecemos por redefinir todas
nuestras matrices de arriba vamos a
tener una equis pero en su versión de 3
x 3 y ésta va a ser igual a b
y vamos a hacer que la última fila sea
la que cambia de matriz en matriz
entonces aquí tenemos de efe pero sabes
que mejor o mejor si vamos a hacer que
la de enmedio sea la que cambia de
matriz a matriz para que no creas que
esto sólo funciona con la pila de esta
abajo o sea también se puede hacer con
la fila de enmedio y de hecho se puede
hacer con la pila de hasta arriba pero
vamos a hacer la de enmedio entonces
tenemos aquí x 1 x 2 x 3
y después d
efe
entonces cuál es el determinante de x y
vamos a sacar el determinante de x y
para sacarlo esta vez vamos a usar esta
fila
porque esa es la que nos conviene así es
que el determinante de x es x 1 x 1 por
su signo que en este caso como es una
matriz de 3 por 3 lo más fácil es
dibujar nuestro tablero de ajedrez de
signos que se acuerdan como iba a llevar
más
- - - - más
no aquí ya me equivoqué estamos aquí
entonces aquí hay un menos y aquí por lo
tanto tiene que haber un más menos más
menos más baja ese sí es nuestro tablero
de ajedrez decidimos entonces x1 está
aquí o sea que le toca este signo o sea
menos x 1 por el determinante de la sub
matriz de tachar la pila y la columna
osea bs.f
y después nos toque aún más
2 por el determinante de seguro esto ya
lo puedes hacer con los ojos cerrados x2
quitamos y quitamos acb efe
a ser de efe y ahora nos toca un menos
menos x 3 por el determinante de la sub
matriz que nos queda de quitar la fila y
la columna que contiene un x 3 o sea nos
queda a b d
de d
y listo ahí está el determinante de x
haber pero creo que este tablero de
ajedrez me va a probar al rato entonces
vamos a borrarlo de una vez y vamos a
redefinir nuestra matriz ya y esta
matriz va a ser igual a vamos a dejar
exactamente estas dos filas tal cual
como están en la matriz x o sea nos
queda aquí
d
efe pero la fila de en medio vamos a
ponerle otra cosa que en este caso va a
ser de 1 2 y 3 y cuál es el determinante
de y pues va a ser muy parecido al
determinante de x y vamos a sacarlo a lo
largo de esta misma fila en que la fila
que está distinta entre estas dos
matrices y entonces lo que nos queda es
como estas dos matrices son igualitas
excepto por esta fila y vamos a sacar el
determinante a lo largo de esta fila
entonces lo que nos queda es el mismo
signo menos después de 1 y 1 en lugar de
x 1 y a la hora de sacar el determinante
de la sub matriz pues la sub matriz va a
ser exactamente la misma o sea porque
tachamos la fila que contiene allí uno
que es la única fila que está distinta
entre estas dos matrices y nos queda el
determinante de la sub matriz bs
sí
efe que es exactamente el determinante
de la misma su matriz que nos queda acá
entonces ya podemos dejar de hacer
tantas cuentas y para el siguiente
término sabemos que es de 272 sumado por
el determinante de ac de f
este mismo determinante y después nos
queda menos de 3 por el determinante de
a b d
bien ahora vamos a definir a la última
matriz de 3 x 3 adivinen cuál va a ser
la matriz zeta que va a ser exactamente
igual a estas dos matrices en la primera
fila y en la última fila o sea vamos a
tener aquí a b c
d efe
pero en esta pila lo que vamos a tener
es la suma de estas dos pilas aunque
entonces aquí vamos a tener x uno más de
uno
x 1 más 1 en este lugar vamos a tener x
2 más de 2 x 2 + 2 y en esta última
entrada vamos a tener x 3 más de 3 x 3
más de 3 y ahora vamos a sacar el
determinante de zeta y lo que más nos
conviene es usar esta fila entonces
tenemos la primera entrada que es x 1 +
con su signo es más o menos aunque aquí
tenemos un signo menos por el
determinante de echamos está ahí está y
nos queda bs.f b
al igual que aquí y aquí y después nos
vamos con la siguiente entrada que tiene
un signo + - +
más la entrada x2 más de 2 x 2 más de 2
por el determinante tachamos tachamos
hace de f
efe igual y nos toca el signo menos 10 x
3 más de 3 x 3 más de 3 por el
determinante de tachamos y tache más si
nos queda
de d
que es igual a igual muy bien entonces
creo que ya sabes dónde va esto entonces
podemos observar que si sumamos este
término con este término lo que nos
queda es este término na o sea los tres
tienen este determinante de esta matriz
y este es menos x 1 + menos de 1 y eso
lo que nos dáis menos x uno más de uno y
todos están multiplicando a este
determinante aunque entonces esté más
este nos queda este término y lo mismo
pasa con estos términos o sea este
término más este término nos da este
término y finalmente debería de subrayar
lo distinto verdad
este término más este término nos da
este término y finalmente este término
más este término nos da este término
bien entonces eso lo que nos dice es que
el determinante de x más el determinante
de g es igual al determinante de zeta
aquí entonces ya demostramos esto para
las matrices de 3 por 3 recordando otra
vez hay que hacer hincapié en esto
porque es muy importante que estas tres
matrices son exactamente igual en toda
la matriz excepto en una fila ok y justo
en esas filas la fila de z es igual a la
fila de x más la fila de y entonces pues
lo que tenemos que hacer ahora es
demostrarlo para cualquier matriz de n
por n para saber que realmente cierto de
forma general y no nada más para los
casos de matrices de dos productos de
tres por tres pero hay que mantener este
ejemplo en mente es mucho más fácil
visualizarlo para matrices de tres por
tres porque en matrices de n por n a
veces puede ser difícil
qué estamos haciendo entonces vamos a
empezar por hacer más espacio
entonces vamos a volver a empezar por
redefinir todas nuestras matrices vamos
a empezar por x x va a ser una matriz de
n por n al igual que jay-z pero esta
matriz
tenemos esta matriz que es la típica
matriz a con sus entradas a 11 a 12 no
seguimos está el n a 1 n en la segunda
fila tiene a 21 a 22 y así hasta a 2 n
y pues no vamos a saltar muchas filas el
chiste es que cuando llegamos a la
décima fila vamos a reemplazar esa fila
por otros números que van a ser
distintos no sé en lugar de hacer los
típicos ahí j
ahora van a ser x 1 x 2 y así hasta
llegar a x m y más abajo pues tenemos
otra vez el resto de las filas con puras
entradas as
aunque hoy aquí llegamos a n1 y n2 y así
está en m y ahora vamos con nuestra
matriz ya que también va a ser una
matriz de n por n o sea si ésta es una
matriz de 10 por 10 entonces ésta va a
ser una matriz de 10 por 10 también
aunque y tenemos aquí la matriz que va a
ser idéntica a la matriz x excepto en la
décima fila
ok en la primera fila tiene al a 11 en
este mismo a 11
después a 12 y así hasta llegar al 1 ene
y después del 21 a 22
hasta llegar a 2 n y todas estas pilas
van a ser iguales hasta que lleguemos a
la décima fila ok en esta décima fila en
lugar de tener el mismo x1 de esta
matriz
ahora vamos a poner un 1 y un 2
y todas estas entradas van a ser algo
que pueden ser distintas
estas x cotas hasta llegar al de n
y después otra vez aquí en el resto de
las filas vamos a tener exactamente las
mismas entradas que en la matriz x en
todas estas entradas que son las as con
algunos subíndice o sea que aquí tenemos
a en 1
n 2 y así hasta llegar al a nm ok y está
ahí pues si es tener una matriz de 10 x
10 y este era la séptima fila ósea y es
igual a 7 entonces ésta también va a ser
una matriz de 10 por 10 y ésta también
va a hacer la fila 7 y ahora vamos a
poner a la matriz zeta
también hacer una matriz en evergreen
aunque es igual va a tener las mismas
pilas excepto en la décima fila o sea
que aquí tenemos a uno a uno dos y así
hasta llegar a 1 n después a 21 a 22
a 2 ene y entonces todas estas filas van
a ser exactamente iguales a las primeras
y menos un filas de equis y b y gay pero
cuando llegamos a la misma fila esta
fila va a ser exactamente igual a la
décima fila de x más la décima fila de y
aunque entonces aquí tenemos x 1 más 1 x
2 más 2 y así hasta x en más de n
ok esto es nuestra y es imagina que es
distinta en cada una de las matrices
pero el resto de la matriz
todas estas otras filas también van a
ser exactamente iguales a las pilas de x
ya las filas de iu aunque entonces aquí
tenemos a n 1
n 2 y así hasta llegar a n
m
este es un caso muy particular y es en
este caso tan particular que vamos a
sacar el determinante de z entonces
empecemos por sacar el determinante de x
que le he estado llamando mucho
últimamente tal cual determinante de x
para sacar este determinante voy a usar
la anotación de suma espero que se
acuerden del vídeo pasado esta suma
y pues vamos a sacar el determinante de
x a lo largo de esta pila que es la pila
que está distinta entonces lo primero
que tenemos que hacer es encontrar el
signo de esta entrada y para hacer eso
lo que hacemos es tomar el menos 1 y
elevarlo a la potencia de la fila y la
columna en la que se encuentra ok
estamos en la fila
y estamos en la primera columna o sea
que aquí va un 1 aunque hay ese es el
signo de esta entrada
este es el signo que nos daría nuestro
tablero de ajedrez en caso de que
tuviéramos nuestro tablero de n por n y
supiéramos en cuál entrada buscar
entonces multiplicamos el signo por
nuestra entrada que es x 1 x 1
y por el determinante de la sub matriz
que nos queda de eliminar esta fila y
esta columna y pues para denotar a esa
su matriz lo que vamos a hacer como
estamos tachando la única fila que tiene
x y todas las demás entradas son as
entonces pues podemos pensar que hay una
matriz que tiene puras entradas as y al
final de cuentas si tachamos la única
fila que no tiene hadas entonces la sub
matriz de esa esa matriz a ok la sub
matriz y j donde j es cualquiera de
estas columnas está su matriz va a ser
igual a cualquier sub matriz de x que se
tome en la entrada y ok entonces aquí
nos tocaría la sub matriz x y 1 pero
esta sub matriz es exactamente igual a
la suma triste
y uno pero mucho cuidado aquí le estamos
poniendo puros uno es cuando aquí
estamos usando la anotación de suma y la
suma va a correr a lo largo de todas las
columnas desde la primera columna o sea
desde que jota es igual a 1 hasta la
enésima columna o sea cuando jota vale n
entonces aquí tenemos que poner en el
lugar del número de la columna que en
este caso fue la primera columna
tendremos que poner j j
j
j y listo
este es el determinante de x
esta expresión de suma lo que hace es ir
sustituyendo el uno el dos el tres y así
hasta el número n en cada uno de los
lugares donde aparece la jota y sumar
todas esas cantidades aunque hay
entonces nos queda tal cual el
determinante de x así es que vamos a
sacar el determinante de elche
el determinante de g y eso es
exactamente igual a la suma desde que
jota es igual a 1 hasta n de el signo de
nuestra entrada ok el signo de nuestra
entrada que es menos 1 a la y más j por
nuestra entrada por de jota por el
determinante de la sub matriz que nos
queda de quitar la fila y la columna ok
y otra vez como vamos a quitar la única
fila que no tienen términos as entonces
esta suv matriz es exactamente la misma
su matriz que está sub matriz aunque hay
que es la sub matriz
j y finalmente saquemos el determinante
de z determinante de zeta
aunque éste también lo vamos a escribir
en su forma de sume la suma hoy aquí me
faltó estos palitos de la suma van estos
perritos de la suma y es nuestro signo
en la entrada y coma j por nuestra
entrada que en este caso es x j más j
por el determinante de la sub matriz que
nos queda de eliminar la fila y la
columna correspondiente y como estamos
tachando justo la única fila que es
distinta de las demás matrices y a la
matriz a entonces aquí nos queda la sub
matriz a y jota y me imagino que tú ya
sabes perfectamente qué es lo que voy a
decir ahorita pero aquí tenemos que
estos términos son exactamente iguales a
la suma de estos dos términos que
tenemos que estas cosas son idénticas a
estas dos cosas
y los términos restantes estos dos
términos si los sumamos nos queda este
término entonces desde jota igual a uno
hasta n vamos sumando término con
término y nos queda esta suma así es que
el determinante de x más el determinante
de y es igual al determinante de zeta y
listo ya terminamos de probar para este
caso remarcó muy particular en el que
las tres matrices son exactamente
iguales en toda la matriz excepto en una
sola fila y además la fila que es
distinta de una de esas tres matrices es
igual a la suma de las pilas que son
distintas de las otras dos matrices ok
este es el único caso en el que podemos
hacer la afirmación general de que el
determinante de x más el determinante de
g es igual al determinante de zeta
no es el caso para nada es el caso y
déjame lo escribo por aquí
no sucede
se ve que si z es igual a x más que eso
no implica para nada implica que el
determinante de z sea igual al
determinante de x no es el determinante
de jay ok
bien entonces los determinantes no son
lineales con respecto a la suma de
matrices en general con respecto a las
operaciones entre matrices sólo son
lineales con respecto a que algunas
filas sean la suma de otras filas de
otras matrices que sean idénticas entre
ellas excepto en esa fila bueno espero
que encuentres muy útil este vídeo y nos
vemos próximamente